[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gibt es mal wieder ein ganz
einfaches rezept nämlich einen
marmorkuchen mit spekulatius keksen oder
mit lotus keksen ich muss sagen lotus
schmeckt ja wie spekulatius keks aber
irgendwie schmecken die logistik so
einfach nochmal ein ticken anders und
die hat man vor allem auch das ganze
jahr über eigentlich zu erste tat machen
mit verschiedenen böden und füllungen
aber ich habe mir gedacht kommen in der
weihnachtszeit backe ich sowieso
generell viel aufwendige dinge wirklich
heute mal ein bisschen was einfach es
ist schön sonntagskuchen den ja auch
alle ganz einfach nachmachen können die
basis ist sozusagen einen marmorkuchen
und da wird dann verfeinert mit keksen
ihr könnt stadt spekulatius oder lotus
keksen auch cookies verwenden also des
amerikanischen cookies oder einfach
euren lieblings keks den könnt ihr dann
damit rein geben ich bereite es jetzt
auch mit kokos blüten zucker zu weil das
einfach noch mal so einen intensiveren
geschmack hat und es in caramel ich
automatisch ihr könnt aber auch ganz
normalen weißen zucker verwenden genau
für die backform ich nehme jetzt hier
gleich einfach so eine mama chor in form
der gugl look form ich probiere ein
bisschen verschiedene formen aus aber so
eine standardgröße sozusagen und ihr
könnt dann einfach auf eure backform
verwenden zum einen fetten der form
brauche ich back transport für den teig
250 gramm weiche butter 200 gramm koks
blüten zucker etwas vanille extrakt und
salz 4 eier die sind schon zimmer war
400 gramm mehl und etwas backpulver oder
verwendetes pigment da ist es schon
bereits mit rein gemisch etwas
sprudelwasser lotus kekse davon nämlich
jetzt 150 gramm 30 gramm kakao und 50
gramm shops das sind die besten und
jetzt startet er direkt mit der butter
und falls ihr mal vergessen sollte die
butter frühzeitig aus dem kühlschrank zu
nehmen damit sie weich wird dann könnt
ihr sehen mit einer küchen reibe fein
reiben in eine schüssel rein und dann
passiert ist weg sie innerhalb von
wenigen minuten dass die butter schön
weich ist und dann könnt ihr sie schön
verrühren bei einem rührteig ist immer
wichtig dass die zutaten schon schön
zimmer waren vor allem die eier dann
damit es nicht anfängt zu flocken das
dann kommt der zucker dazu
etwas salz sei es immer wichtig bei
süßem gebäck damit der geschmack gut
rauskommt und bei hefegebäck dann
nämlich immer einen teelöffel salz
außerdem finde ich schmeckt man sogar
wenn das salz vergessen ist dann
schmeckt der hefeteig nicht so gut das
team vanille extrakt und jetzt einfach
mit dem handrührgerät oder mit der
küchenmaschine für etwa 560 schön weiß
cremig verrühren wobei das nicht weiß
cremig wird durch den eco bos blöden
zucker sondern ein bisschen dunkler aber
trotzdem schön cremig
noch
so sieht die macher jetzt auch schön
cremig und jetzt gibt dir die eier dazu
aber immer eins nach dem anderen also
wieder schöneren und die eier ungefähr
30 sekunden immer mit einrühren bis
alles schön homogen ist
[Musik]
jetzt da kleine ich hier noch die lotus
kekse
[Musik]
das passt schon gut und jetzt wird der
teig hier fertig gestellt zum einen mit
dem bug mail falls ihr keinen bock mehr
habt dann jetzt backpulver und mehr
vermischen und dazu 7
dann könnt ihr mineralwasser oder milch
verwendet das sprudelwasser hat man
einfach mal ein bisschen so ein lockeres
ergebnis
dann nur ganz kurz einrühren
auch schon ein paket dabei
aber nicht
anstößig ich habe gelernt ich nehme
immer jetzt den spritzschutz damit nicht
hier alles wie in der vergangenheit
vielleicht mal passiert ist explodiert
selten oder
[Musik]
das gute regionale mineralwasser von
kevin
[Musik]
und dann jetzt die backform schön
einfetten
den ofen hab ich auch schon vorgeheizt
auf 170 grad hitze
[Musik]
dann gebe ich da jetzt
ungefähr ein drittel des tages schon mal
rein
[Musik]
und der rest wird jetzt schokoladig
damit jetzt aber das kakaopulver und
ischgl und vermisse ich jetzt cacau mit
bisschen wasser
[Applaus]
oder milch falls menschen jetzt
bist du nicht glatte masse entsteht und
die könnte jetzt ganz schnell und kurz
in den teig anrühren
hier ist es einfach immer nur wichtig
dass der teig sobald mehr dabei ist
nicht mehr so lange gerührt wird damit
er schön locker bleibt und nicht so fest
wird wie so ein kleister denn dann geht
nicht mehr so locker auf und
die shops nicht vergessen
oder verteile ich den teig jetzt hier
drüber
[Musik]
gebe ich jetzt noch die restlichen kekse
drauf
und damit mama kuchen wird schön
marmorieren mit einer gabel also ich
steckte dann rein und dreht es so ein
bisschen
fertig und bereit für den backofen
[Musik]
der stein kaffee
ich mache den frische
recht bestimmt kann
jetzt haben wir ihn erwartet
[Musik]
jetzt amara kuchen gebacken ich habe ihn
in der form hier draußen einfach mal so
zehn minuten stehen lassen dann gestürzt
und jetzt ist er komplett abgekühlt und
ihr könnt ihn jetzt natürlich so lassen
es gibt ja die menschen die sagen maurer
kuchen schmeckt mir auch ohne glasur
einfach nur mit puderzucker bestreut
oder ihr könnt ohne schwegler so drauf
machen ich mache jetzt da eine karamell
glasur drauf eine karamell
schokoladenglasur soweit ich finde dass
es ganz gut passt und ich habe jetzt
hier schon mal karamell schokolade in
der mikrowelle geschmolzen die
schokolade beziehungsweise kuvertüre
muss natürlich geimpft werden damit sie
auf die richtige temperatur kommt das
heißt hier mit den schokoladenstückchen
einfach die warmen gewordene schokolade
herunterkühlen zu zwei drittel ein
drittel also zwei drittel habe ich schon
geschmolzen ein drittel ist jetzt mit
dabei damit kurz heruntergekühlt und
dann wird es noch mal ganz kurz erwärmt
entweder noch mal kurz aufs wasser
baustellen oder in die mikrowelle oder
mit einem heißluft führen darüber gehen
und dann ist die perfekt zum überziehen
und das temperieren solltet ihr schon
machen damit die schokolade gleichen den
schönen glanz bekommt und auch festwirt
und auch bei raumtemperatur fest bleibt
keine grauen schleier bekommt deswegen
wird kuvertüre immer temperiert
das gebe ich hier ein bisschen kokosfett
rein damit dekorateure etwas
dünnflüssiger wird oder nehmt ihr euch
am besten ab gitter und ein blech
drunter dann könnt ihr nämlich die
herunter tropfen dekorateure schön
wieder auffangen und manche machen sie
auch so das könnt ihr auch gern machen
wenn der kuchen gebacken erst dann könnt
ihr ihn noch warm mit aprikosenmarmelade
einstreichen dann verstopfen nämlich
sozusagen diese poren und dann ist die
kuvertüre darüber etwas glatter muss
aber nicht sein ich finde da kommt noch
zusätzlich so eine süße mit reinen dem
man eigentlich braucht und in der
konditorei macht man das auch ganz gerne
zum haltbarmachen
meist daneben saftiger bleibt aber bei
uns wird der kuchen immer sofort
gegessen
entstanden
einfach drüber diesen ein bisschen
verteilen können
[Musik]
und wer möchte kann jetzt noch lotus
gegen
ich möchte hier noch ein bisschen drüber
reden und dann lasse ich jetzt die
kuvertüre fest werden und später problem
wird den kuchen
und die übrige kuvertüre darunter die
können wir zum beispiel zu rocky road
verarbeiten das sind so kleine
schokoladentäfelchen oder würfelchen und
da könnte doch mit marshmallows
reingeben und erdnüsse und
gefriergetrocknete himbeeren so ein
bisschen was fruchtiges salzige ist
knusprig ist und was weiches und dann
habt ihr die schokolade verwerteten
haben noch kleine leckere teil
ich fühle jetzt die rocky road hier in
kleine silikonform hinein dann habe ich
immer so ein und riegel ich habe jetzt
hier marshmallows rein und erdnuss oder
gesalzene gefriergetrocknete himbeeren
cacau lips und das ganze ist immer nur
schöne resteverwertung und dann kann man
hier unten rein noch gefriergetrocknete
hinbegeben
zustande schöne dekoration sie fest
werden lassen und dann auch verschenken
[Musik]
also das ist den kuchen probieren okay
das ist ein marmorkuchen mit keksen
guck mal
ich habe schon vorher
gehabt gut aus oder max eine gabel oder
isst du mit der hand
wenn ich
da hab ich mit probieren
immer schön wie schokoladen und
das wohl
wenn du den beschreiben würdest wie
schmeckt ja
okay
also so luftig und
vielleicht schokolade karamell ich ja
okay
und meinst du den sollte man mal
nachmachen zum ausprobieren
willst du dir auch packen
ich glaube er hat hunger ich bin top
tierschau wird jetzt nur noch also
probiert das rezept gerne aus ich finde
den kuchen auch richtig lecker einfach
mal eine abwandlung eines mama kuchens
schön winterlich weihnachtliche und
vielleicht schreibt ihr mir gerne auch
mal in die kommentare ob ihr kuchen also
mama kocht meter gelassen oder ohne
schon gut dass somit also ich muss sagen
ich mag es aber mit glasur die karamell
ja so finde ich gut finde ich auch sehr
gut und vor allem am nächsten tag dann
stückl ich das so klein und es war so
mein
kindheitserinnerung überhaupt mit
milchvieh so komplex gegessen das war
schon immer ziemlich lecker also das
rezept findet ihr auf wo finden und das
is ja
und in der app bis zum nächsten mal ist
ja was machen wir jetzt mal jetzt packen
wir nochmal was oder zusammen
für deine schwester so machen wir das
sagen
und jetzt mal wirklich hast wirklich
geschmeckt
gut
heute ist es so anständig und da gehört
so richtig
jeder wartet noch so kommt noch was
drückt sie mir diesen spruch
[Gelächter]
du bist cool weist
normalweise
[Musik]